[Dave:] This is Brian Gawalt who works on text analysis,
which is a really important problem for search engines if we want to be able to do
a better job of identifying the right documents.
Tell us how that works.
[Brian:] There are lots of different approaches, but the model that we tend to take
transforms them into a really nice hashtable representation.
Text is long and unwieldy and unstructured and prose flows and goes,
but computers like things that are nice and structured
and amenable in familiar things like lists, hashtables, etc.
What we've got is a way to turn unstructured text
into a data structure that computers are really happy with.
One of those is the hashtable and the ???.
We can start with a document that says, "Obama announces candidacy,"
and we can turn that into a representation of that document, and imperfect representation
that just says let's keep track of every word and the number of times that word appeared
in the document.
We would just go through and say "Obama"--go to the hashtable and hash Obama
and make sure the value associated with it is 1.
Similarly, "announces" hashes to 1, and "candidacyO hashes to 1.
If we were dealing with longer documents, these values would grow,
and the number of elements in the hashtable would grow as well.
Then we come across document 2, and we can represent that with a whole new hashtable.
"Barak Obama elected"--Barak maps to 1, Obama maps to 1, and elected maps to 1.
If it also said "President" down here, we'd add more and more keys
and keep track of the value associated with each one.
When it comes time to relate documents to each other, like we would do with our search engine,
we can look and say, hey, there's an overlap between these two documents
and the fact that they both used "Obama."
If we've got enough documents and there are enough patterns between them,
then we can start saying I'm seeing this pattern of "Barak" shows up in a lot of them
or "candidacy" or "announcements" seem to come from him a lot.
Now you've got a way of expanding this key word that maybe we're searching for "Obama"
and the search engine can think when you say "Obama" you're really talking about
this wide pantheon of topics that all of the do with the 44th presidency.
[Dave:] How did you get started working on this?
[Brian:] Well, I was an electrical engineer, and I went from circuits to signals
to statistical signal processing, and it turns out I was working on how to tell
if a cell phone is sending a 1 or a 0, and the math behind that wound up being
broadly applicable to general problems, including how to tell if an email is spam or not.
That's kind of the entrance to text processing in general from my background.
[Dave:] I see. So what's the next step then?
Well, a lot of the stuff that we work with all comes down to being able to compare
two documents and then finding out how that comparison matches
to whatever you're target is--detecting spam or not.
All that works really well if the documents are next to each other,
living close to each other within a single system,
but that gives you a maximum of how many documents get analyzed.
So distributing the solutions to these problems
is, I think, where a lot of energy is being put forth.